Let's look at the answer to our quiz.
We would ask which of these are true.
L1 capacity is less than L2 capacity.
This should be true because
the L2 cache needs to
have hits for
things that were L1 misses.
So if L2 has the same or
lower capacity than L1.
The not many things that miss in
L1 will actually be hit in L2, and
we want the L2 to still
have a lot of hits so
that things don't go to even
slower caches or even to memory.
The L1 latency,
should it be less than L2 latency?
And the answer is yes.
We look first in L1 cache not
because it has a better chance of
finding the data than the L2 cache, but
because it has a lower hit latency.
The number of accesses in L1 cache,
is it lower than the number
of accesses in L2 cache?
This is not true.
All of the accesses, load and
stores, go to L1 cache but
only those that miss in
L1 cache go to L2 cache.
So, the L2 cache usually has
a lot fewer accesses than L1 and
finally, L1 associativity needs
to be equal to L2 associativity.
This is potentially true,
but usually it isn't.
Why?
Well because the L1 cache needs to have
a low hit latency and need not
have the capacity of the L2 cache.
Similarly for associativity the L1
cache because it needs to be fast
can have a lower associativity where
as the L2 cache can be slower so
we can maybe afford
a higher associativities.
So typically that's what happens,
L1 has a lower associativity than L2.
So this is also not true.